yo man this is our third show and we
already got our first
i told you show we already got our first
i told you so
why you rolling what's up like jimmy
almost saw like jimmy conway and
goodfellas
what did i tell you what did i tell you
what did i tell you about the clippers
in game seven
what did i tell you about the clippers
in game seven yesterday you picked a new
one
i tried to told you no i didn't tell you
they were gonna win i told you the
moment was too big for them
and they would fold under the pressure i
told you even though the nuggets
were trying to and successfully became
the first team
to ever erase two three one deficits in
the same postseason
not to mention doing it in back-to-back
series
even though they had come all the way
back i told you the clippers look tired
they look shook and ain't no such thing
as halfway crooks
i told you i could trust that team so i
don't know
who looks worse is it the clippers for
choking or it's for people
or is it people like you for actually
believing in that franchise that they
actually get it done
in game seven so i tried to tell you let
this be a lesson to you moving forward
listen to me i know what i'm talking
about i will never see you wrong
shouldn't trusted him
before i come back at you though before
i come back at you
yeah major props for the mob deep
reference within that rant okay so i'll
give you that
i like that a lot thank you i thought
michael smith
yeah shame on me shame on everybody out
there because i thought clipper jokes
were a thing of the past we don't even
roll like that anymore nobody tells
clipper jokes
that was a different era you you look at
this team going into the season you have
the best offseason in the nba
in in retrospect it wasn't so great but
it looked like they had the best
offseason in the nba they picked up
kawhi
leonard fresh off a championship and
they traded for paul
george so you look at this and we said
all the all the cliches that we said oh
i hate to play that team defensively
you got paul george you got patrick
beverly
you got kawhi leonard who some people
thought not me
but some people thought was the best
player in the nba
last year lebron misses some time and
all of a sudden kawhi leonard is the
best player in the nba
no we just got fooled we got fooled they
did mike they choked
they absolutely choked and you know how
i feel about doc rivers mike
i love this doc river we all love doc we
all love doc rivers who doesn't love
doubt
and i i appreciate i appreciate his
attempt
his gracious attempt to say you can put
this on me
yeah he he he bears some responsibility
he bears some response but
first of all i want to hear you i want
you guys to listen to what he had to say
and then we'll set then we'll tell you
where he's writing where he's wrong
check it out
this team never was able to reach his
full potential
how good did you think this team could
have been and um
did the expectations were they ever too
heavy for this team no
uh we didn't meet him that's the bottom
line
i'm the coach and and i'll take any
blame uh
for it but we didn't meet our
expectations
clearly because we had uh in my opinion
we'd still be playing
mike doxamaster so he takes he takes
some responsibility
but he didn't answer the question the
question was
were the expectations too big for you
yes they were too big why were they too
big
i know kawhi leonard was was bad last
night he was
they were too big because we thought
they had two stars
and for most of the playoffs they had
one star
you could break you can you could blame
doc rivers if you want go ahead blame
doc rivers
but they went all in for two stars and
they got a star and a quarter a star and
a half throughout the playoffs am i
right
am i right or am i right you ca
well you're kind of right you're kind of
right because uh they had a star in the
regular season
playoff p has become a running joke he's
the latest in the long line of clipper
jokes okay
so you're right they had one and even
even their one star
didn't really show up last night i mean
it's not like kawhi leonard played great
last night he was the one person
to whom i gave the benefit of the doubt
yesterday and even but he has played
great in the playoffs though
he has been great earlier absolutely one
great game seven and that's where it
matters
he's he's a maid man he's a made man
he's got his two rings he's got two
finals mvps he might be going for three
if he
stayed in toronto that's a conversation
for another day all right but as far as
doc rivers goes okay you want to start
on top let's start at the top
look i'm not saying it's all on doc and
there are some
reasonable reasons not to call them
excuses but
reasons why this team did not meet those
realistic expectations given the
off-season that they had which was still
the best offseason
in the nba those reasons are a lack of
chemistry
which whether it was the way they
managed players loads early in the
season or took nights off early in the
season
or the pause that everybody had to deal
with everybody dealt with the pause
but this team in particular once they
got back to playing in the bubble after
the restart this team in particular had
i think four guys three or four guys
leave the team for funerals so there was
just some chemistry issues
and that's the thing that bothered me
the most about people like you yesterday
and throughout this series throughout
this collapse which saw them blow leads
of
16 19 and 12. so i started off
by saying what did i tell you i'ma tell
you what you told me yesterday a lot of
people fell for this particular banana
in the table
they're the most talented team they're
the best
team everybody fell for the talent thing
and how many teams have you seen
that they're the best team that money
could buy but when it comes time to be
counted they worth confederate currency
to court our former colleague peter may
at the boston globe one of the best
leads
ever written i still remember that lead
the best team he wrote that about the
blazers and the lakers
and that collapsed by portland against
kobe and shaq's lakers the best team
that money could buy
was worth confederate currency when it
came time to be counted and that's what
you saw
last night now as far as doc rivers goes
mike
i'm sorry i love doc but sometimes
numbers don't lie he has the dubious
distinction
of being the only coach in nba history
to blow three
three one leads and his text and context
context does matter
but his record and close out games in
particular close out games
he has the worst winning percentage and
clinching opportunities in postseason
history
14 and 27. now
i love doc he's a great coach and an
even better man
and that's saying a lot that is but it
does have to start at the top
it does have to start at the top in this
case and
our boy chris haynes from yahoo sports
has confirmed he's already put the
speculation to rest
that doc rivers is coming back next
season which makes sense
but given all the reasons you talked
about about how how short a window
this group might actually have he goes
in the next season
as for all intensive purposes a lame
duck coach because they don't get it
done next year
c bomber is moving on oh okay look look
i i i i will go in on
i said a lot there i said a lot i said a
lot i know i like that i'll go in and
dock with you to a degree
but sometimes the numbers are bs
sometimes numbers are just full of it
absolutely i'll tell you what a close-up
you know what a close-out situation is
here's a close-out situation your team
is up
three games to two you can clinch you
lose game six you win game seven so you
take a loss in a close-out situation but
you win the series so
that's that's that is garbage i want to
i'm going to take that stat
ball it up and throw it in the trash
okay if you numbers are
okay look i'll do it hey there you go
there you go no i was doing it for my
to my own convenience i'm sorry but it
is what it is the organization has never
been past the second round
yes there is context associated with
each of those three one collapses
we know what happened with with the with
the clippers a few years back with chris
paul and the lob city clippers we know
what happened in orlando yeah you could
go to it you could point to this
particular series
point to his own players in the fourth
quarter asking out
because they were tired i love this
graphic
i love the graphic i mean like you know
you've never been to the conference
finals 50
years you deserve all the jokes that are
coming your way until you can
until you can knock the door down but
let me ask you all right so doc rivers
3-1 and it's interesting how we look at
it
you know we we we play all sides of the
street on it
on one hand it's a players league right
yes
so if lebron james wins a championship
we're like hey lebron we look at
lebron's record
in the finals as if it's a players
league
but then when the team doesn't meet
expectations now we're going to put it
back on the coach
i think he bears some responsibility but
we gotta say the same thing
let's go back to well okay i guess we
are but let's go back to this offseason
because i kind of think it wasn't as
successful as we thought it was
and not just because they lost but
because i went back
mike and and i guess i was just i was
doing other things last summer
i don't know i had i had other things
going on another thing you and me
right yeah me both right so i guess i
just didn't think about
the enormity of the trade that they made
really for one guy now they talked they
talked me into it they talked all of us
into it you know really
we're not really trading for paul george
we're trading for paul george and kawhi
leonard
no that's exactly right sam sam prestige
is sitting there today saying
no you gave me this for paul george okay
okay this is what i got from you from
paul george yeah not one how many first
round picks
two not three five
so they got three protected first
rounders
throw in two pick swaps and a good
and two good players two good players
out of this
for a guy for a guy who had four field
goals
so the stats will be going around five
first round picks
paul george had four field goals go
ahead so what was it really
was it really a great off-season for the
clippers so now
even if they made it to the finals so if
they make it to the finals and they lose
now you got one more year because i've
been wrong in the last two days hey it's
family i i'll be
transparent with you guys i've been
wrong last year i've been saying there's
one on one it's not one-on-one one's two
years so
next year they're both in their contract
years they can both leave
yeah paul george and kawhi leonard so
let's say you win a championship next
year
and they leave so it's one championship
for the clippers is that worth
everything that you gave us yes is it
worth it yes
wait wait a minute first of all let's go
back you don't have no matter how sam
presti
feels about the trade which you should
feel great about it you should feel good
no matter how good about it
no but they don't get kawhi leonard
if they don't bring in paul george as
well so effectively yes that trade was
worth it in order for you to assemble
a dynamic duo of kawhi leonard and paul
george
how dynamic we just showed you why well
listen
i'll get i'll get to next season in a
second but if they get one championship
out of them let's spin this forward and
say they got a two-year window
and look if they win the next year they
probably stick around they're probably
not gonna go anywhere they might
who knows but bottom line is dude
he won a championship he left toronto
he's like okay good thank you that's
well that's true that's true wait when
we get
we getting off off track hold on my
point is
go ahead we just showed we just showed
the graphic as to why
five first round picks for paul george
and by extension kawhi leonard
is worth it if you're the clippers
because you've never been in the
conference finals
let alone a championship still have it
absolutely
you make that trade and they still had a
phenomenal off-season but let me tell
you what the silver lining might be
let me tell you where the silverado
might be and you kind of alluded to it a
second ago when you quoted lebron from
the pep rally when he joined the heat
not one now two not three not four
could this be i was thinking about this
could this be
their 2010 as in the heat got together
they weren't they you got it you know
and i mean it was embarrassing
think about the the is there were
narrative around lebron james
around spoelstra around that experiment
after the
the the debacle against dallas and then
they go and they win two more
or two championships and then they end
up with four straight finals and and the
in the heels
are history could if they managed to get
their act together and by the way going
back to doc for a second when kawhi says
we gotta improve our basketball iq
when they say our chemistry has to get
better i'm sorry that's that's on the
coach it's not on doc rivers
to put the ball in the basket or to not
be tired in the fourth quarter and ask
out but nonetheless
he does bear some responsibility but
what i'm saying is could this be
the setback for this team this
particular group because i'm not going
to hold lob city
and their shortcomings against kawhi and
paul george i'm not going to hold
orlando
against the clippers and talking about
doc rivers three three one blown leads
i'm not gonna hold
49 years of clippers existence against
this group so
on a positive side could this be the
thing that propels them going into next
year because i said yesterday man
i don't know how much you could take
away from this whole bubble experience
especially one that cost those four
players i mentioned those four key
players i mentioned time to gel
when they had to leave unfortunately for
family circumstances
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you a
couple things then i want you to talk
about my denver nuggets okay
my denver nuggets oh okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely you're next i'm just
lying
okay i'm just lying i'm just lying right
now okay
uh two things i want to say you're a
smart dude
i mean you're you're a smart dude i love
your
your sense your comfort with nba history
that is a really intelligent take
that you just gave except 2010
2010 2011 really 2011
miami right right right right yeah
except 2020
l.a clippers smart tape there's a butt
coming what's the but what's that yes
wrong
it's wrong i'll tell you why it's wrong
because at least
in 2011 for miami they had a finals mvp
and dwyane wade dwyane wade was getting
it done in 2006.
young player he had he had an older
shack on the team
and they all knew it was dwayne wade's
team he was putting up 40-something
in the nba finals like game six that
clinching game i think he went to the
line like 17 times or 20 times whatever
it was he was bawling
so in 2006 he says i'm a finals mvp
lebron comes to the team
and they probably were having nice
fights for a while oh you're the man no
you're the man you're the man you're the
man oh yeah i love you bro i love you
bro
and then eventually they figured out the
hierarchy okay
lebron yes even though i was here first
team this is your team
and we need to follow your lead yeah the
clippers
already did that mike they already did
it
it's kawhi's team and
they don't have so if kawhi is lebron
paul george can't play like d wade paul
george didn't even play like chris
bosh i mean paul george he didn't step
up to the moment i think that's a big
part of it
and kawhi oh what a damning statement
kawhi made
after the game and you probably
shouldn't be talking like this when you
when you suck in the second half
but he says our basketball iq needs to
improve okay
i want to hear i want to hear from that
i want to hear you on that like three
days from now
i don't i don't want to hear you say
that after you were terrible
in the second half of game seven
you're up 3-1 in your team
your team history blew the 3-1 overall
lead but blew a bunch of leads in this
series
i don't want to hear you talking about
that and he was a part of it and he was
a part of it in game seven it wasn't
like he balled out and everybody else
left him hanging i mean he struggled too
but but but let me say this though it
sounds like what you're saying about the
clippers
if going and going with my comparison to
the possibility
of them using this year to fuel them
going forward
it sounds like you're saying they are
what they are and they and they
that this is who they are they're just
yeah but i i don't i don't necessarily
i don't necessarily buy into that i got
them i do think that
i got the clippers what do you mean
go ahead go you go you go no i'll just
say i overestimated the town i'll just
go i'll be quick on this i overestimated
their talent
and that i really thought they were
getting uh
you know two top ten players
they got one they got one top ten player
because you know and this is what i love
about the nba i love this about sports
in general but the nba in particular
and we have these debates and we we go
back and forth mike about okay who who's
a top 10 guy who's a top 10 guy in the
nba and when you start
having these conversations with people
you figure out
there are a lot of good players in the
nba that
when you say all right you get to your
10 and somebody will inevitably say
what about this guy how about dame how
about jimmy butler
how about how about this guy how about
this guy he's like oh wait a minute i
forgot about him how about luca
yeah you know so paul george may have
been in the top 10 last year
but i don't think he's there right now
do you well okay
well no of course of course not at this
moment but i mean let's
look i mean the the playoff p thing i
mean he look he's got a lot of soul
searching to do this off season and
maybe you're right
maybe they are who they are as an
organization
from a history standpoint maybe they are
who they are
you know this particular group
well i can look i i i could you know and
i wasn't
when i said that they were going to lose
i was talking about the team that we're
going to get to in a second
we mean we we talked for 20 minutes damn
there and they ain't talking about the
better
them give them something but let me say
this though
um i saw the way this series was going
and i saw the look of a team
that knew what was happening that i saw
in the clippers i'm like
they know it's slipping away and they
can't stop it and they really don't have
any answers
for nikola jokic uh and not to mention
jamal murray and just the way
the nuggets were playing but i'm saying
benny goodwill from yahoo was on
yesterday we'll get to them in a second
i know how to transition hold on come on
yahoo in the sec yesterday and he said
that you off you can't skip these steps
you know nba history
sometimes you got to have a setback that
sets you up for your comeback for next
year
and and the clippers were built
regardless of what paul george says they
were built to win it this year
it didn't happen doesn't mean they can't
win it next year for the same reason
that you
and a lot of people bought into the hype
this year all the way up to game seven
people like me told you don't trust this
team
you